some motivational videos are toxic and I
don't think it's intentional I don't
think these motivational guys are doing
it intentionally I've even probably done
it before in the past but that message
can really do some damage to certain
people there's two phrases I want to
share with you today and if you get
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel let's go
into the first one you ready for the
first one that goes viral what would you
do if you had only 30 minutes left to
live whatever it is do that now if you
have 30 minutes left to live would you
go spend time with your kids or your mom
or your dad or your okay if I had 30
minutes left to live would I be shooting
this video right now hell no if I had 30
minutes left to live would I go to the
gym no if I had 30 minutes left to live
would I go to work today no so if I
lived every second of my life as if I
have 30 minutes left to live I will not
go to the gym I will not go to work I
will not be reading any books I will not
be doing anything just being around my
family and that would mean that's a
pretty bad life because your thinking
every second of the day you're about to
die so let me do this for the rest of my
life that's a toxic message to give to
the average person because the average
person's like so what's what's a word
for me to go after my you know work so
hard because I'm going to live as if I
only have 30 more minutes left to live
because that's what life is and you know
there's perspective it's perspective
it's such a great perspective now it's
confusing now can you do that if you're
worth 100 million dollars sure can you
do that you if you're watching this if
you right now spend the rest of your
life as if you have 30 minutes left to
live how long do the math until you run
out of your savings say you got fifty
thousand dollars in a bank and your
expense are 10 grand a month so if you
live like that in five months you're
running out of savings then you dip it
into your credit card debt you can only
do that for five months and you got to
go back and make sure get a job make
some money pay your bills it's not
unaffectable so imagine starting a
company you're the founder of it and
eventually this company ends up having
nearly 11 trillion dollars of assets
under management and your name is Larry
Fink whether you like this car or not he
said the following statement recently
real estate and art are the new gold art
is the new gold and by the way it's not
just Larry Finn talking about this Ken
Griffin but a piece from David Giffin in
2015 for 300 million dollars as The
Interchange William de Cooney I'm in
Miami At Art basil with Goldman Sachs
with all these investors you know what
they were talking about alternative
assets one of them being art and the
company that's sponsoring today's video
is Masterworks here's what Masterworks
does for those of you that cannot afford
to buy Picasso or Banksy or any of these
Arts that are worth millions of dollars
but you'd like to own a share of it
Masterworks allows you to do that
historically Millionaires and
billionaires have been the one buying
Arts but recently with Masterworks the
average day-to-day person can now do it
2022 was the best auction year ever
highest total from Big Three auction
houses nearly 18 billion dollars is what
they did last year and last time
inflation was this High Contemporary Art
appreciated at an average of 20 per year
and that's from the MW index the way it
works is each offering is qualified with
the SEC and it's broken into shares and
when one resells you get a slice of the
potential profits and by the way they
already have 700 000 members on
Masterworks and paintings have sold out
in minutes to keep up with demand they
release new offerings on the platform
regularly and you can get Priority
Access at the link in the description
below let me give you another one the
speakers this company when I first
started doing business I would hear
these speakers give the same exact
message here's what the message was
imagine if one day you make so much
money that you never have to work a
single day in your life ever again and
and I remember this one time uh one of
the guys I was working with and you know
he's like you know you know what dream I
bought into what do you remember that
one time that one guy from states that
imagine getting so you know building a
business that you never have to work a
single day in your life ever again I
said yeah that's the dream I bought into
and I'm like yeah but I also bought into
that dream when I was a brand spanking
new insurance agent thinking that's the
life and then I eventually ended up
becoming a vice president in the
meetings where these guys are really
talking and the same guy from stage that
I looked up to that said that message
from stage I sat down with him one day
and I said let me ask you a question
because I have a hard time with this
message that he's given right because
I'm confused my dad is 81 years old he
was in the hospital for five days last
week he's working every day he's 81.
okay he had a surgery and they were so
worried about the surgery they had to go
back and do it again it was an angel and
angioplastic within two hours apart
because they thought this was it for him
my dad's working is 81. not because he
has to because he works so I go to that
guy the same guy that gave the message
and I'm struggling with this
contradiction I say hey did you by any
chance like when you said that because I
see how you work right now was that just
something you say when people are
smaller to get him to sell the dream or
what is that like he says you have to
say that so what do you mean he says
because if you really tell everybody the
work required what it takes to run a big
business they would never start in the
first place he says but now that you've
actually worked hard to become the level
you're at right now you've built a
multi-million out of your business he
says now you realize what it took to
build this guess what if you stop you're
going to lose this business if you want
to take you to the next level you got to
keep it going because a lot of people
are targeting your business now I sat
there and I said what an interesting
thing he says but here's a question for
you do you want to stop I said no he
says if you stop your business is going
to take a hit so I said because when I
watch you working you have these
responsibilities with the church you
have these responsibilities with this
business with that investment with this
with that I said how many hours you work
a week because I do six to eighty or 80
hours a week as how come you don't say
that from stage to everybody he says
because I cannot say that to the newest
agent because if he knew that he
wouldn't do it
but he needs to go pay the price the
same applies with having kids think
about it nobody tells you what it is to
have kids they just tell you how awesome
it is to have kids then you have kids
and then you realize for each kid you
have it's a company you run for the rest
of your life do you understand what I'm
saying to you I have four kids right now
one of them is calling me literally she
called me on FaceTime send up you know
how many times she's call me already
matter of fact let me show you I don't
every time she called me and I'm gonna
have her say hello to you and watch this
baby
and I read 20 chapter book chapter book
pages no you didn't what did you learn
baby
[Music]
okay
was it a good kitty cat or what kind of
kitty cat babe
one of them oh no
okay
and the coach said to Mommy that
did you watch two hours of a movie today
or did you actually practice basketball
okay who's proud of you
[Music]
who loves you baby
yeah okay can you say hello to everybody
I got two people watching you right now
and a few more people on on YouTube
space
say hello
what's your name
what's your full name
okay baby I see you shortly okay
well yeah baby
[Music]
I'll call you afterwards babe bye-bye
[Laughter]
it's baby I got four kids
they're four companies
the difference with these companies you
can't sell the companies and be like I'm
moving on these four kids they're
companies from the day they're born till
the day I die they're my companies how
awesome is that but nobody told me
that's what kids are all about
great school boyfriend girlfriend
breakup education homework with say yeah
it's a lot of stuff right so look why am
I telling you this year ask the question
when somebody sells you an ID and say
does that is that really true I wanted
to know the work I'll never forget I
cornered a man named Greg in Orange
County this is December of 2002. they
were fake performers Michael Jackson
Joan Rivers and Robin Williams they were
like actors that are acting like they're
Michael Jackson they're doing the stuff
I cornered this man Greg I said I got
only one question for you he says what's
that he says you just got to tell me
this financial services business I had
my series 766 31 26 life and up I said
just tell me if I work 80 to 100 hours a
week for 10 years will this work he said
if you work 80 to 100 hours a week for
10 years I tell you this is going to
work for you and this guy was a
Christian man and I believed him it was
a very honest man straight up man I said
look at me my eyes when I'm saying this
to you he's looking at my ass got my
smell was like 60 year man I admire a
lot at the time that's all you have to
say to me and left sometimes if you're
not afraid of work people just got to
tell you straight up what it's going to
be like okay for me I don't mind doing
the work if you don't mind doing the
work you can go do the work but later on
there's other responsibilities that have
come but you're going to be a better
version of yourself that you don't
recognize today and I can't wait to meet
that person and trust me for you you
ought to be excited about meeting that
next level person you know that whole
thing about imagine being rich one that
we don't have to work a single day in
your life and you can spend all the time
with your kids and you don't have to
work and you can sleep in and you can
come home at one really so what so you
can tell your kids daddy used to work
hard but not anymore daddy was a hard
worker 10 years ago if you only knew
your kids don't care there's more caught
than Todd and parenting they want to
know if you're working hard today they
want to see you today not what you did
20 years ago and you're like talking
like one of these guys that you're a has
been no one admires that kids want to
see you in the hunt today and you get to
be involved with them so they duplicate
you so again imagine if you can spend
the rest of your life you know question
that a little bit more before you jump
to conclusion realizing life is not
about not working and just kind of
chilling there's greater things to life
and the best things in life require a
lot of work the best things you escape
that you're not going to get the highest
the best highs in life I want to
experience the best highs in life and
I'm sure you want to do the same as well
anyways if you have value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel if you want to watch another
video I got a video I did I don't know
how long ago maybe a year ago or so it's
titled how to raise successful kids if
you've never seen a click here to watch
it take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]